Welcome back.
We're on problem number 7.
If a and b are positive
integers, and a squared minus
b squared is equal to 7,
what is the value of a?
So there's a couple of ways that
I would think about this.
You could say-- well, this
is actually the way I
would think about it.
Whenever I see something squared
minus something, I
immediately just want to factor
it, and we'll see where
that gets us.
You get that a plus b times
a minus b is equal to 7.
And we know that a and b
are positive integers.
Well, we know this is going to
be a positive integer, right?
You add two positive integers,
you definitely
get a positive integer.
And then we also know that
this is going to
be a positive integer.
How do I know that?
Well, when I multiply a
positive integer times
something and I get another
positive integer or I get
another positive number,
I know that whatever I
multiplied by is positive,
right?
Because a positive times
a positive is positive.
So what does this say?
So these are both positive
integers, and when I multiply
them, I get 7.
So what could they be?
Well, what numbers when you
multiply it can be 7?
Well, there's only
two choices.
1 times 7 because 7 is prime.
7 has no other factors
other than 1 and 7.
So which one's going to be 7 and
which one's going to be 1?
Well, the larger one's
going to be 7.
And the smaller one's
going to be 1.
So you could eyeball this.
You could say, well, what two
numbers when I add them
together is 7 and when I
subtract them, I get 1?
And you can say, well, what
if a is 4 and b is 3?
And that works.
4 plus 3 is 7.
4 minus 3 is 1.
And if that didn't just dawn
on you all of a sudden, you
could do a system
of equations.
a plus b is equal to 7.
a minus b is equal to 1.
Add these two equations.
You get 2a.
The b's cancel out.
Plus 0 is equal to 8.
7 plus 1 is 8.
a is equal to 4.
Then you can substitute back
in or just play around with
the numbers, and you get
b is equal to 3.
So that is choice-- oh, they
want to just know what a is.
So a is 4, which is choice B.
Next problem.
You have a number line here.
Let me draw it nice and big.
I don't know how much
space I'll need.
Have 0 in the middle.
Negative 1, 1.
Let me draw these points
now: t, u, v, and w.
And then you have
x and y here.
And then you have z.
On the number line above,
which of the following
corresponds to the absolute
value of u minus v?
And this is just an
approximation problem.
You might get intimidated, like,
how do I figure out u?
How do I figure out v?
Well, the answer is you
just kind of guess.
Well, you don't guess.
You approximate.
So let's see.
What does u look like?
u looks like-- I don't know.
If you're eyeballing it, it
looks like minus 0.8, if I
were to eyeball it.
Maybe a little more?
Minus 0.85?
Because it's almost
at negative 1, but
not all the way there.
I don't think it's 9/10 there.
Yeah, I would say minus 0.85.
I'm just eyeballing it.
So let's just say u is
equal to minus 0.85.
And what's v?
v looks about 2/3
on the way to u.
So let's say v is equal
to minus 0.6.
Once again I'm just-- let's
say minus 0.66.
I'm just approximating
once again.
So it's minus, right?
And they're both negative
numbers, and they're both
almost at 1.
So what is the absolute
value of u minus v?
Well, that's the absolute value
of minus 0.85 minus v.
So minus minus 0.66.
So the minus minus
becomes a plus.
So what's minus 0.85
plus 0.66?
Well, that's roughly
minus 0.19.
And if I'm taking the absolute
value of that,
that becomes 0.19.
0.19, roughly 1/5, and there's
no other number around.
Roughly 1/5 is around here, and
there's no other number
there even remotely close,
so that's going to be x.
And another way you could have
thought about that, if you
didn't want to approximate,
use numbers.
I do that just to make sure.
The absolute value, when you
subtract two numbers and you
take the absolute value, you're
essentially saying,
well, what's the distance
between the two?
What's the positive distance?
I don't care whether one's
larger or one's
less than the other.
So you're essentially saying
what's this distance, this
distance here that's equal to
this, to this expression?
So that distance, that
positive distance, is
approximately equal to x, even
in my not-exact drawing.
And if you look at how they drew
it-- actually, even in
the way they drew it.
Oh, sorry!
They did u minus w.
So then it actually makes even
more sense, because w
is more like 0.5.
I misread the problem.
This w is equal to
more like 0.5.
So the absolute value of u minus
w is going to be equal
to the absolute value of 0.85--
sorry, w is minus 0.5.
It's in the negative domain,
so minus 0.85 minus 0.5, so
that equals minus 0.35.
Absolute value is equal to 0.35,
still is equal to x.
And they did that.
I was just approximating
that x still works.
But according to the drawing,
it makes even more sense
because we're actually talking
about this distance.
Sorry, to w.
Let me do it in a different
better color.
This is what u-- not this.
This is what this represents.
The absolute value of u minus
w represents this distance.
And that distance is the
same as the value of x.
And it really makes sense if you
just look at the distance
between u and w in the book.
It's almost exact.
This actually looks like
it was drawn to scale.
Next problem.
And that's choice
C either way.
Even when I did it wrong
the first way.
I didn't do it wrong,
I misread.
To give myself a little
bit of credit.
Problem number 9.
Although you won't get much
credit if you misread
when you take it.
A number n is increased by 5.
I write these out as I read
them, is increased by 5, and
the result is multiplied by 5.
This result is decreased by 5.
Finally, that result
is divided by 5.
The whole result is
divided by 5.
In terms of n, what is
the final result?
Well, what can we do here?
We can divide the numerator
and denominator by 5.
So this 5 will cancel out with
this and this, right?
Because you distribute.
So you're left with n plus
5 times 1, right?
Because this just becomes
a 1, this becomes a 1,
this become a 1.
n plus 5 times 1-- I won't
write the 1, because it
doesn't matter anymore--
minus 1.
All of that over 1.
So we could just ignore that.
So it's n plus 5 minus 1.
Well, it's n plus 4.
Just get rid of the
parentheses.
Plus 5 minus 1 is n plus 4.
And so that's choice D.
Let's see if I have space
to do the next problem.
Or time, actually,
more than space.
I will actually wait to do it
in the next video, just so I
don't rush things, which
I tend to do.
See you soon.